You may think it's pretty inefficient that we have to
type a URL into the browser every time we want to grab
some data from last.fm's API. There has to be a
more efficient way to do this and you're right. We can
write a simple Python program that uses the JSON and
request libraries to do exactly what we did manually a few
moments ago. If we run this program right here, let's think
of what it returns. Look, the data that this Python program
returned is exactly the same based on data that
you saw in the browser a second ago. This
program was less than 10 lines. First we specify
a URL, then we simply say request that get,
that URL and call.text, in order to get the
text. We assign that value to data. We print
type of data which we saw was Unicode, and
we print data itself, which was the JSON object.
But if we go back and look at the JSON
object itself, we see that it's in this funky string format
that makes it very hard for us to parse out
the interesting information. We could write a Regex to parse out
what we want, but that can get pretty painful really
quickly. The JSON library will make interacting with JSON data as
easy as 1, 2, 3. Let me show you how.
We've modified our script ever so slightly. After initially assigning data,
we reassign it. We say data equals json.loads
data. What json.loads does is it interprets a string
and assumes that it's a JSON object. By doing
so, we convert the JSON data into a Python
dictionary. We'll see that when we print type
data. Once we convert the data into a nicely
structured dictionary, we can get the interesting bits out
as if we're simply accessing a dictionary. For example,
typing data artist. Let's see what this script
produces now. As we can see, what we return
here is that the type of the object is
a dictionary and then we have a Python dictionary.